connaissent et cyril hanouna animateur
vous connaissez cyril hanouna ambianceur
blessés cyril hanouna producteurs aux
commandes d'un peu tout l'homme la
marque est le grand chef d'orchestre
enfin j'avais orchestre plus de musique
darbouka que de 24 heures mais n'a pas
du tout mais on ne connaît pas cyril
hanouna chanteur aime ça m'a donné des
idées je vous propose de regarder cette
image de cyril d'un chanteur c'est
vraiment très important c'est c'est bien
pour la chanson
or
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je
les mariages de ma soeur et ses sourcils
chat avait pas droit de faire ça bastien
le droit que je raconte papa toit aux
sources où la sélection de tapas
emmanuel chain la whey d'ouvrir ce qui
fait quoi jeter les gants
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
rituel patrick quer le cgt soit ce que
ta soeur est toujours mariée non parce
que oui c'est peut-être ça